Let's work on forming the /θ/ sound.
Keep your mouth slightly open.
Spread the blade of your tongue and place it in between your top and bottom teeth.
Release air over the tongue and through your teeth.
Touch your hand to your throat and make sure you don't feel any vibration.
Here's the /θ/ sound in the beginning of some words.
thought, thin, thrill.
And here it is in the middle.
pathways, mathematics, anything.
And here it is at the end of some words.
teeth, both, moth.
Listen to these pairs of words to hear the contrasting sounds.
think, sink.
three, tree.
path, pat.
path, pass.
Here are some sentences that use the /θ/ sound.
He thinks mathematics is a myth.
Theo has three thin teeth.
Nice work!